“I am having a fantastic time at PyData.”
“It’s been excellent, the talks have been
a mixture of academic applications and business applications.”
“I really love the PyData community,
and it’s one of my favorite conferences.”
“PyData is an educational program of NumFOCUS.
We are delighted to work with local communities
all around the world to put on events that
bring together people who are developing these
tools as well as the users of the tools”
“I think it’s pretty amazing that PyData
is not only about the talks,
it’s a lot about the people and the software.
We are meeting here, just networking, sharing knowledge,
and also contributing to open source projects.”
“I think what makes PyData special
or PyData London in particular —
is that it’s a conference and a meetup that is
from the community,
by the community,
for the community.”
“I’m really excited,
and I’m also really excited to see
how the community can really further my work
in the future
by giving me some ideas.
So, the questions I’ve had have been really
thoughtful.”
“Nobody can innovate in isolation.
You have to be plugged into the community.
And that’s why things like the PyData conference,
where you can meet hundreds of exceptionally bright people
who are really keen on what they do
is something we support.”
“By sponsoring an event like PyData Amsterdam,
we are able to give back to the community
and help to drive the innovation of open source technologies like Python forward.”
“We love sponsors.
We love them so much.
So...”
“There’s definitely something here for everyone.
I personally have made some new friends,
talked to some really cool professionals, and
you know, it’s been a fantastic experience.
I highly recommend you come.”
“I went to bed last night with a grin on my face
simply because I got home and just felt
happy
with the quality of conversation
and the quality of the people that I met all day
yesterday
here at the conference.
It makes me happy.
Yeah, it’s fun.
You should come along.”
"We leave every PyData conference more impressed than the last."
pydata.org